with the bang a year we've just had 2024
has a lot to live up to you're following
a year that gave us moments that are
going to be remembered for a long time
to come with iconic quotes that will
live on in the hearts of anime fans
inspiring lines such
as and of course kill yourself truly
moving phrases that the anime Community
have taken and made their own but what
else has this New Year got in store for
us well for once we not buried under a
Cascade of high-profile sequels this
classroom of the elite sukimi is
Apparently one of the best is I haven't
finished yet that I need to one of the
best romances of last year is back with
the dangers in my heart looking like
it's only going to get even better from
there mhal season 2 now I know what
you're all thinking are we going to see
more of the most iconic role in anime
our number
one maybe I think this is your best work
yet but enough about sequels what else
do we have we got more romance more
Slice of Life more girls more isekai a
lot of isekai again and of course we got
the Action Baby Woo look at that this oh
yeah shit's about to go
down he's about to [__] [__]
[Music]
up but before we move on this video is
sponsored by honai star rail a game I
have never ever played before so let me
tell you about this game I have never
ever touched honkai star rail is a
free-to-play turn-based RPG that has
been awarded the best game of the year
2023 on the Google Play and app store
and the TGA mobile game of the year that
I have definitely 100% honestly not
already spent way too many hours playing
because to reiterate I have never played
this game before but if I did I would be
really excited about the brand new 2.0
update that just dropped because it
introduces us to the world of penacon
the first whole new world that has been
added since the game released and along
with that comes a bunch of new five star
characters we got Black Swan a new
five-star win type nihility character
who has abilities like yada yada yada
who cares about what she does look at
her just look at her God I'm so excited
to pull for you you know is what I would
be saying if I played the game but we
also got Sparkle a new mischievous
little girl who's a five star Quantum
type Harmony character that will fit
perfectly into my hypothetical roster
because I barely have any hypothetical
Harmony characters in it there's also a
bunch of new exciting updates including
new scenes new characters and if you log
in now there are 10 free warps awaiting
you and another 10 for logging in for 7
days and you can claim a free five-star
limited character doct to ratio too but
wait there's more click that link in the
description to download the game today
and you can use the code on screen for
an extra 50 Stellar Jade hold on a
second I just got to note down this code
thank you very much to hoers and hongkai
star rail for sponsoring me today back
to the
[Music]
video honey is there a way to to un
virginy ourselves well it's official
guys while us decrepit sex havs were
busy en acting quitus these damn virgins
were secretly getting wizard Powers I'm
sorry to say weebs but I've let you down
but the fight is not over you can finish
what I couldn't accomplish okay so our
guy here has the ability to read minds
by touching people because he's a virgin
but the Catch 22 is the man is such a
giga virgin that he can't ever touch
anyone except for
o oh it's that kind of show well nothing
says true Bromance like helping your
mates lose their virginity and honestly
how can you complain my man is really
putting the top in top husband material
he's even using the Forbidden eron Yer
technique to RIS up his fellow bro it's
been a while since we've seen a show Go
full BL bro love but suffice to say this
is the most homoerotic thing we're going
to see all
[Music]
season
I think I like men now after the witch
from Mercury try to revolutionize the
genre it's good to see Mecca going back
to its roots just gay guys in it but on
a serious note don't make the same
mistake as me and almost skipped this I
thought this was just going to be
another standard real robot show people
are dying on the battlefield fighting
for their lives you are witnessing the
true horrors of War then out of nowhere
this guy drops in and just just listen
to his theme
song for those of you unfamiliar with
Mecca this is like the equivalent of
people fighting for survival in the
brutal world of Attack on Titan then
suddenly all might drops in this is what
happens when everyone working on the
show knows exactly what they are doing
this is a mecha show by meca fans for
meca fans with the gungho Top Gun
bravado that comes with it just a bunch
of manly men doing manly stuff saying
completely manly things to the fellow
manly Bros yeah you better win your
fight cuz I'm coming on your ass Bo I'm
coming for that ass solo leveling okay
this is meant to be the big one this
season and if you've seen my previous
video on the Mana you'd know that I'm a
big fan and these opening episodes seem
decent they held nothing back when it
came to the sheer violence compared to
the original web comic here Yuki Sao is
as always bringing the hype with his OST
animation seems
good and this opening is what I hear in
my head when I'm getting a kill streak
in Counter
Strike but I am a little cautious
because A1 pictures is doing a pretty
good job with the animation but let's be
real Here solo leveling is not coming in
here as the Pinnacle of Storytelling one
big thing that made this title Stand Out
was that the art was absolutely Godlike
not just good Godlike they gave us some
of the best heart pounding action scenes
you can find in webcom I so the real
question is is this anime going to be
able to match that cuz when I look at
this art I'm thinking the action has to
be like Demon Slayer jit in season 2
level you know what I mean cuz take that
away and we have a story that's not too
dissimilar to the truckload of power
fantasy isekai we see every season the
main character ends up more perfect than
Kyo Side characters become as useful as
Yamcha this is an Unapologetic power
fantasy show that lives on the rule of
cool and if we don't have similar
Godlike animation what more can the show
give us that we haven't already seen
arise all right actually I'm sold we got
a few villain anime this season and this
was the one that definitely interested
me the most and yes it is purely because
I am a sucker for time Loop anime coming
from the manga the seems to have a curse
for mediocre anime adaptations like
Lucifer and the biscuit hammer it looks
like one of his works is finally getting
a decent adaptation I'm not too familiar
with this one but it does give me hope
that we're going to get the spirit
Circle adaptation we
[Music]
deserve account successfully created you
are are now signed into
Discord did this [__] just hit
him with a virginity punch mapper have
come to us with another anime original
with another self-proclaimed virgin
protagonist in an old school delinquent
Showdown anime I'm not sure what's up
with all the freaking virgins having
superpowers this season and why is it
always the guys what about all the
female virgins come on anime we need
some representation for the freaking
highman Squad you watch subbed anime
don't you yeah I mean to sub anime you
mean subbed anime
right yeah sure all right now we're
talking time for some real anime change
Soldier is the show to watch if you want
to be a respectable human being did I
say respectable I meant the exact
opposite of
that ah yes my favorite job slavery
that's how it works right yes it's an
anime about a guy who gets superpowers
by being a slave to a bunch of of hot
anime girls man what the [__] is going
on with this season now before anyone
gets angry this is basically just power
world with a degeneracy mod sometimes
you have to respect a title that knows
exactly what it wants to do and hones in
on doing that one thing really well even
if that thing is Awakening a new fetish
every episode this is the rare type of
series that has plots but also has plot
you already know if this is the type of
show for you but I will say the fight
scenes went unexpectedly hard in the
manga and this action animation is not
exactly the cream of the crop but you
can only expect so much when the team is
working with one hand if they chose to
put their focus on another certain type
of scene I'll still be a happy man cuz
let's be honest guys who doesn't want to
be stepped on by a group of hot anime
girls am I right
guys trigger back again to save anime
from the Jiu-Jitsu fan base this time
with dunge meshy or delicious and
dungeon which no one actually calls it
even though it name was on the original
Japanese manga going into this I thought
this was just going to be a Simple
Cooking Show where some adventurers
explore some dungeons eat a bunch of
weird monsters have a good time I was on
board for this but then I think the
episode that that really sold me was the
one where they find the Living Armor now
in most shows Living Armor is just
normal armor that's imbued with magic
which is what you and everyone else
assumes but dungeon mesy takes his
common idea and goes nah that's baby
[__] so as our hero fights one he
notices something that looks like an egg
and thinks to himself why is there an
egg why can the armor see me even though
it has no eyes maybe this is a living
thing after all but it's completely
Hollow doesn't die if I behead it and it
moves too rigid to be a slime and too
silent to be a swarm but by some good
detective work he manages to uncover a
biological explanation behind the Living
Armor that not only makes sense but also
makes it edible that made me go damn
okay I've never really thought about it
like that this is just one of the
monsters we find in the series every
single creature has careful th put into
their biology their ecosystem even the
most common fantasy monsters we're
familiar with are given their own unique
take the insane amount of creativity in
the world building makes this feel more
like a nature documentary with a cooking
twist and add to this a core cast with
banter reminiscent of something you'd
find in konosuba and you got yourself a
pretty damn good show well this now in
at the same time as frean all I can say
is fantasy anime fans are eating good
right now huh huh all right what show we
go
next oh she's going to
die you know I think she still could be
savable uh yeah she still could be
savable yeah the city's still savable
still could
[Music]
see what did I tell you he saved the
city guys it's saved sometimes all the
show has is the rule of cool and
sometimes it's enough ishira might just
be that show it's some ruined fantasy
land where a bunch of Dark Soul bosses
gathered from all over the world to take
part in a no holds bar Battle Royale
bloodbath isekai protagonists Undead
Warriors every episode introduces a new
stupidly overpowered character for the
True Battle Royale experience that will
have you placing bets like this is a UFC
match this might not be the prettiest
looking show of the season but this is
it if you want some turn your brain off
edgy fun so you watch subbed
anime nah I'm into dumb you mean dubbed
an no I went into the show completely
blind thinking it was some cute parody
of the magical girl genre then 5 minutes
in I realized wait a godamn
minute I thought chain Soldier was going
to be the only thing bringing the cult
of this season but now we have BDSM
botchy if she was a villainess and the
thing is the scenes here go even harder
but the problem is it's comedic enough
that I don't know if I should laugh or
be turned on sometimes if you want more
culture in your life give this one to
watch this might not be your proudest
fap but it'll certainly be your
funniest here has an anime called
Hokkaido gals a super adorable about
some super adorable girls living in
Hokkaido
[Music]
what the hell do you need me for now if
you don't know anything about Hokkaido
well it's Northern Japan it's really
cold it has some of the best food you
can find in the country and it's got
really thick milk and then you have the
Gus now for anyone wondering how These
Girls Aren't freezing their butts off in
this weather you need to understand that
in Japan short skirts protection to the
cold follows the same logic as RPG armor
feels like I'm wearing nothing at all
I'll be real with you this is clearly
just paid propaganda by the haido
tourism board and God damn it is [__]
working yo is he going for the aroner
Strat too the wrong way to use healing
magic would have been a more accurate
name for this show actually I feel like
having healer or healing in your title
has become a PTSD inducing trigger word
for us at this point but I actually had
a lot of fun with this one for one not
so obvious reason I'm into dumb for most
people this probably looks like another
run-of-the meal isekai junk food cuz it
is but for someone with a trained eye
like me I can tell the difference
between a white guy and a white guy
between a White Castle and a Five Guys
and to any isai Trashman out out there
who know what I mean this feels like the
latter not enough healing for you while
we have The Unwanted Undead Adventurer
featuring a dead skeleton protagonist
slowly leveling his body back up oh
that's a totally different thing uh
excuse me necromancy is just healing for
those who believe in the 5-second
rule hey look a middle-aged protagonist
and he's adopted a cute little BB ah so
it's a simple Slice of Life about an
older gentleman taking care of a BB I
can Vibe with
that all right so the bird can talk well
that's okay every Slice of Life needs
its Quirk nowaday surprise isekai [__]
okay well I wasn't expecting an isekai
but I'm not going to complain oh he's
starting his own training company and
learning the
economics I get it now so it's going to
be a spice and wolfes anime with an isai
twist surprise magic [__] so we can use
magic in the real world that makes sense
it's an isekai after all surprise
psychics [__] okay so I guess there are
psychics in the real world and he's
getting tailed by a shadow organization
of Psychics now while training goods in
an isekai with a talking bird who's
secretly a 3,000 year old demon this
show is amazing we got ourselves a cute
little romance this time with the most
precious cinon roll who has trouble
communicating cuz she's deaf making her
the actual lore accurate Comey son this
is honestly godamn adorable I haven't
seen a story like this since the silent
voice but this seems far more on the
wholesome side and I better stay that
way cuz if anything happens to this girl
I will be shooting on
site Studio bones are going through
their 25th anniversary and they pulled
out all the stops to celebrate we got a
new anime original sci-fi tokos satu
style show that takes place in the world
that's a little bit of Blade Runner a
little bit of Caroline Tuesday with also
gay girls in it I feel like more and
more I'm relying on anime original shows
to get my sci-fi fixed and this clearly
has one of the most intricate and wellth
thought out worlds of the season and
normally I love the show don't tell
approach where I get to discover the
world and story as it naturally develops
but this beginning feels like just a bit
too much information has been emitted
what are the characters trying to do
here why are we fighting who the hell
are these people in the first place I'm
going let it cook because I smell a
potential delicious meal coming along
but I hope I at least get a look at the
menu
soon ah Another Love confession victim
of the godamn anime fireworks well you
couldn't have picked more cliche way to
start off a romance plotline in your
anime but surely they can't drag this on
for too long right look he clearly likes
her she clearly likes him this
[__] traveled to another world
for her and now the bloody married
they're married for God's sakes I've
seen anime romance [__] before but
how long can this possibly take
[Music]
wait a minute they actually gave him a
second chance this has never happened
before in the history of anime this is
it she's given him the perfect layup bro
got an open goal from two yards there's
no way you can [__] this
up it's okay I'm
calm
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month too
author Curtis xen basil dysfunctional
degenerate flabber Walky husbando Hub
Jon a thick Mike 808 misaka 12315 pain
patchet Pony Stark shouting zombie water
gist VT and everyone else my patreon for
helping support me for this month and
making this video possible guys I hope
you're having a happy New Year even
though we're already [__] month into
the New Year it's always a grind for me
that first month when I have to get the
best of anime and the winter 2024 anime
video out back to back but hopefully I
can go back to my normal schedule now
anyway though I'm going to keep it short
today there's not much more for me to
say I've been gig and I'll see you all
next time